bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va aborder
un courant philosophique que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'effleurer à de nombreuses
reprises dans ma vidéo mais que je n'ai
encore jamais exposés pour lui-même ce
courant philosophique c'est l'empirisme
dont le représentant le plus connu est
le philosophe anglais david yum
mais c'est un courant philosophique dont
on va trouver des ramifications
dès l'antiquité l'empirisme c'est ce
qu'on appelle une théorie de la
connaissance
autrement dit c'est une doctrine de la
philosophie qui cherche à expliquer ce
qu'est la nature de la connaissance est
ce que sont les moyens de la
connaissance
autrement dit l'empirisme va chercher à
répondre à la double question que veut
dire connaître et comment reconnaît-on
ce que l'on connaît l'empirisme a connu
ses heures de gloire au xviiie siècle
mais je disais que on en trouve des
germes
dès l'antiquité notamment avec la
philosophie sceptique mais également
avec l'épicurisme puis avec aristote
mais pour comprendre en quoi c'est
important il faut d'abord que j'explique
ce que nous dit l'empirisme l'empirisme
du grec emperia qui signifie expérience
c'est une doctrine qui nous dit que
toutes nos connaissances
absolument toutes nos connaissances
proviennent de l'expérience sensorielle
je précise sensorielle parce que si je
n'utilise que le mot expérience vous
risquez de l'interpréter dans le sens
courant du mot dans le sens courant
expérience ça signifie la pratique le
vécu donc l'idée que nos connaissances
proviendrait de l'expérience ça
signifierait que c'est à force de
pratiquer quelque chose c'est à force
d'avoir du vécu dans un certain domaine
que nous développerions nos
connaissances en fait c'est pas
exactement ça claudie l'empirisme
empirisme nous dit que toutes nos
connaissances proviennent en fait de nos
perceptions et lorsqu'on parle de
perception on ne parle pas
simplement de perception visuelle la
perception ça désigne l'ensemble des
phénomènes sensorielle par lesquels on
appréhende le monde
donc nos cinq sens font partie de
l'expérience
nos cinq sens sont des modalités de la
perception toute connaissance provient
de l'expérience c'est ainsi qu'on peut
résumer la doctrine de l'empirisme une
fois qu'on a dit ça remet on pourrait se
dire bah oui la belle affaire
évidemment que toutes nos connaissances
proviennent de l'expérience puisque si
nous n'avions pas de contacts
sensorielle avec le monde il ne serait
tout simplement impossible de connaître
quoi que ce soit toutes les
connaissances scientifiques sont bien
basé sur des observations qu'elle
censure et il a parlé de connaissances
indépendamment de notre expérience
sensorielle indépendamment de nos
perceptions
alors c'est une vraie question qui est
très légitime mais il faut savoir que au
xviiie siècle l'empirisme était en
concurrence avec une autre doctrine
qu'on appelait le rationalisme et dont
le principal représentant étaient des
cartes dont on a déjà parlé dans une
autre vidéo et pour des cartes
il n'est pas vrai que toutes nos
connaissances sont issus de l'expérience
pourquoi parce que selon des cartes il
existe ce qu'on appelle des idées ine
c'est à dire des idées présentes dès la
naissance
indépendamment de toute expérience
lorsque l'on vient de naître
on n'a encore fait aucune expérience
donc d'un point de vue empiriste nous
sommes ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
toile vierge
nous sommes un esprit sur lequel rien
n'a encore été imprimé alors que pour
des cartes et pour les rationalistes
nous possédons déjà certaines idées et
même si ces idées ne sont pas encore
développés elles sont présentes en nous
pour que ça vous paraissent le plus
clair possible ses idées in et recouvre
tout le domaine de la logique la logique
n'est pas quelque chose qui dépend de la
perception
la logique c'est une faculté de l'esprit
une faculté de l'entendement qui n'a pas
besoin de la perception pour exister
si je dis par exemple que jean est plus
petit que pierre et que pierre est plus
petit que paul la conséquence logique
c'est que jean est plus petit que paul
mais ça ça ne dépend d'aucune expérience
je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir pierre-jean
épaules face à moi pour accepter la
conclusion logique de mon raisonnement
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un
syllogisme en logique
le syllogisme est parfaitement
indépendant de l'expérience on pourrait
dire que un syllogisme est vrai
indépendamment de la vérité du contenu
des propositions
peu importe que pierre existe que paul
ou que jean existe peu importe qui est
plus grand que l'autre
ma conclusion reste vrai de par sa
cohérence interne de par sa cohérence
logique donc voilà très grossièrement
résumé ce que signifient les idées inné
chez descartes et si je fais cette
précision
c'est pour montrer à quel point
l'empirisme a pu apparaître comme une
doctrine assez novatrice à l'époque
moderne une doctrine qui était loin de
faire l'unanimité
parce que pour certains elle consistait
à réduire les facultés de connaissance
de l'homme alors maintenant on va
rentrer un petit peu dans le détail de
cette doctrine et comprendre comment
elles fonctionnent
david yow mais les empiristes nous
explique que toutes nos idées sont issus
de nos expériences
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
si on prend un cas concret que l'idée de
chaleur qui est bien une idée c'est à
dire quelque chose d'abstrait cette idée
chaleur elle est totalement dépendante
de nos expériences de la chaleur c'est à
force d'expérimenter la chaleur c'est à
force de sentir d'éprouver la chaleur
que le concept de chaleur peut émerger
et avoir un sens et c'est vrai que le
concept de chaleur n'aurait strictement
aucun sens pour un être qui seraient
dépourvus de sens pour un être qui
seraient incapables de par sa
constitution physique d'éprouver la
chaleur ce serait comme de vouloir
expliquer l'idée de profondeur à un être
en deux dimensions
ça n'aurait strictement aucun sens donc
il faut bien que nous soyons pourvu
d'une sensibilité au sens originel qui
nous permettent d'appréhender cette
sensation de chaleur dont va dériver
ensuite l'idée de chaleur
autrement dit qu'est ce qu'une idée une
idée c'est la généralisation d'un
certain nombre d'expériences qu'on va
résumer dans un concept et cette
transformation de la sensation en idées
c'est ce qu'on appelle un processus
d'abstraction abstraire c'est enlever
s'est retirée qu'est ce qu'on enlève et
bien on enlève le dénominateur commun à
toutes les expériences de la chaleur par
exemple et ce dénominateur commun la
c'est le concept de chaleur c'est l'idée
de chaleur c'est ce qui reste quand on a
enlevé de toutes les expériences de la
chaleur ce qui est propre à l'individu
ou ce qui est propre au contexte
parce que bien entendu nous n'avons pas
tous la même sensibilité ce qui sera
perçu comme chopard les uns qui sera pas
forcément perçu comme chopard les autres
pour un méditerranéen 25 degrés c'est
pas spécialement chaud comme température
ambiante alors que pour un belge ou pour
un danois 25 degrés c'est déjà chaud
dont je disais que d'un point de vue
empiriste une idée c'est ce qui résulte
de la généralisation d'une série
d'expériences série d'expériences qui à
force d'être répétée vont donner lieu à
un concept qui va globalisé l'ensemble
des expériences
juste une précision quand je parle du
processus de l'abstraction c'est à dire
le fait de dégager de l'expérience une
généralité un concept abstrait bien
entendu ce processus est inconscient on
ne se dit pas à ça y est maintenant j'ai
expérimenté suffisamment de fois la
sensation de chaleur pour en déduire
l'idée de chaleur non ça se fait de
manière mécanique se fait de manière
automatique
à tel point que nous sommes tous
globalement d'accord sur ce que
signifient les différentes idées issues
de nos expériences nous avons tous
expérimenté la joie nous avons tous
expérimenté la tristesse la colère la
fatigue et c'est parce que nous avons
tous déjà fait l'expérience de ces
choses là que nous sommes capables de
nous entendre sur la définition de ces
termes
certes il nous est fondamentalement
impossible de savoir à quoi correspond
la tristesse chez l'autre parce que nous
n'arrivons pas à sa place mais parce que
nous l'avons déjà vécu nous sommes
capables d'en comprendre l'essence nous
sommes capables d'en comprendre l'idée
donc c'est comme ça selon les empiristes
connaissent toutes nos idées
à force d'expériences par la répétition
de la sensation répétition qui de par
notre mémoire va donner lieu à des
concepts généralisant qu'on appelle des
idées donc vous voyez ici je pense en
quoi l'empirisme s'opposent radicalement
au rationalisme de descartes chez les
empiristes il n'existe pas d'idée ine il
n'existe que des idées acquise
this par l'expérience acquise par notre
rapport sensoriel à la réalité alors
c'est important ici de préciser que dans
les sciences modernes ce qu'on appelle
les sciences dures la physique
l'astronomie la biologie on utilise en
grande partie cette méthode de
connaissances qui consiste à partir de
l'expérience à partir d'une répétition
d'expérience pour ensuite en déduire des
lois générales alors en sciences c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'induction qui est le
contraire de la déduction la déduction
c'est partir d'une loi générale pour en
déduire les cas particuliers l'induction
c'est au contraire rassembler des cas
particuliers rassemblé une multitude
d'expériences localisés pour en déduire
une loi générale et c'est assez
compréhensible par rapport à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure à savoir que la
science elles portent d'abord sur la
réalité c'est à dire sur ce que l'on
peut percevoir il n'y aurait aucun sens
a élaboré une science physique qui ne
parlerai pas de la réalité
or comment connaîtront la réalité on la
connaît par l'observation on la connaît
par la perception
il est donc logique que la perception
soit à la base de la connaissance
scientifique
donc c'est ainsi que se construit la
connaissance dans une perspective
empiriste nous naissons nous sommes une
toile vierge
nous sommes un corps et un esprit qui
nous a encore fait aucune expérience et
au fur et à mesure du temps nous allons
faire des expériences qui pour certaines
vont se répéter et qui vont donner lieu
à l'émergence d'idées c'est à dire de
concepts généralisons qui vont se
cumuler dans le temps voilà pourquoi on
parle de connaissances cumulative dans
l'empirisme à savoir que par définition
plus nous faisons d'expérience plus
notre connaissance s'enrichit plus nous
faisons d'expérience plus nous
augmentons notre connaissance c'est
presque un phénomène mécanique
alors évidemment il ya des cas où cette
connaissance peut régresser
c'est dans le cas de l'oubli puisque la
connaissance ne peut s'accumuler dans le
temps que si on présuppose que nous
conservons la mémoire de nos anciennes
expériences ou en tout cas la mémoire
des idées issues de nos anciennes
expériences
mais si on oublie bien à ce moment là
les expériences qui auront eu lieu dans
ce laps de temps que nous aurons oublié
là forcément elles vont être retirés de
notre corpus de connaissances
personnelles donc la connaissance
présuppose la mémorisation la
connaissance présuppose le souvenir et
c'est vrai que dans notre vie courante
il nous arrive très souvent de réagir à
une situation par rapport à nos
expériences passées et par rapport aux
leçons de nos expériences passées
si quand vous étiez enfant vous avez mis
la main au dessus du feu et que ça vous
à brûler il ya de fortes chances pour
que vous n'ayez pas renouveler
l'expérience pour vous en assurer
parce que votre esprit aura associer la
sensation de brûlure au feu et le
souvenir de cette sensation constituera
pour vous une connaissance du fait que
le feu brûle et d'ailleurs on y
reviendra un petit peu plus tard dans
cette vidéo mais on pourrait presque
critiqué ce comportement d'un point de
vue empiriste à savoir que ce n'est pas
parce que le feu nous a brûlé une seule
fois que ça signifie qui va nous brûler
toutes les fois mais le fait est que
dans notre vie de tous les jours on
préfère quand même s'appuyer sur nos
expériences passées pour réagir aux
situations présentes pour adapter notre
comportement nos réactions à ce qui se
présente devant nous c'est tout à fait
normal et je dirais presque que c'est
tout à fait ça parce que ne pas prendre
en compte les leçons de l'expérience
passée c'est un petit peu agir comme un
nouveau-né perpétuelle ce serait agir
comme un individu qui n'apprend rien or
qu'est ce que veut dire apprendre bien
s'est retiré un savoir de notre
expérience
par exemple si vous vous êtes rendu
compte que par le passé vous étiez
quelqu'un de trop gentil et que
certaines personnes en profiter et bien
un moment donné peut être aurez vous le
déclic de changer votre comportement et
par la suite de vous rendre compte que
les gens profitent et moins de vous
dans ce cas là vous aurez exploiter
votre expérience passée vous aurez fait
en quelque sorte
l'inventaire des conséquences de votre
comportement et sur la base de cet
inventaire vous aurez adapter votre
comportement par rapport à de nouvelles
exigences
donc toutes nos expériences sont des
sources d'enseignement à la condition
qu'on les mette emprunt
sic à la condition qu'on fasse coïncider
nos actes avec nos connaissances dont je
disais que toute connaissance présuppose
la mémorisation et que c'est parce que
nous sommes des êtres temporel doté
d'une mémoire que nous pouvons apprendre
que nous pouvons progresser dans nos
connaissances il ya donc une notion
absolument fondamental dans l'empirisme
c'est la notion d'habitude
qu'est ce que c'est une habitude c'est
une action qui se répète de manière
régulière dans le temps tous les matins
vous avez l'habitude de vous préparer un
café et cette habitude fait que vous
êtes maintenant capable de faire votre
café quasiment les yeux fermés pourquoi
parce que vous n'avez plus besoin
d'investir votre intention d'investir
votre concentration dans quelque chose
que vous avez fait tellement de fois que
c'est devenu quasi automatique
et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle la plupart des accidents se
produisent dans des endroits connus dans
des endroits familiers que vous avez
l'habitude de fréquenter
justement parce que le niveau de votre
attention va baisser mécaniquement
n'avait pas besoin de produire un effort
attentionnel pour adapter votre
comportement dans une situation
habituelle
c'est ce qu'on appelle la mémoire
procédurale qui fait que vous êtes
capable à la fois de démarrer votre
voiture d'allumer votre autoradio et de
discuter avec la personne qui est à la
place du passager
ce sont des gestes qui sont en gras mais
dans votre corps et auquel vous n'avez
plus besoin de porter d'attention donc
l'habitude est une notion fondamentale
de l'empirisme et en même temps c'est
aussi l'un des plus grands facteurs
d'erreur parce que si on veut être
rigoureux il n'y a rien qui prouve que
ce qui va se produire demain sera
conforme à ce qui s'est produit hier
notre expérience par définition il porte
sur les événements du passé pas sur les
événements du futur donc par exemple
comment puis-je être certain que le
soleil va se lever demain je ne peux pas
en être certain je ne peux pas en être
certains au sens où je n'ai rien qui
puisse me le démontrer pourquoi parce
que le fait que le soleil se lèvera
demain ça n'a rien d'une nécessité
logique c'est un phénomène physique qui
certes a toutes les chances de se
produire compte tenu des lois de la
physique
il est rigoureusement parlant je ne peux
pas l'affirmer comme étant une certitude
à 100% je ne
être sûr à 100% que ce qui s'est produit
pendant des millions des milliards
d'années va se produire demain quand est
ce que je pourrais le savoir eh bien je
pourrais le savoir quand ce sera produit
je pourrais savoir quand cette
expérience appartiendra au passé parce
que vous vous avancez dans une situation
que vous ne connaissez pas encore vous
projeter sur le futur des considérations
issue du passé donc par définition vous
prenez un risque
vous prenez un risque vous fait un pari
sur l'avenir donc vous ne pouvez
absolument pas savoir si vous allez le
gagner et donc ça c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la limite de
l'empirisme dont l'empirisme lui-même a
conscience car david youm le dit très
bien toute généralisation est abusive
toute généralisation est abusive
parce qu'on ne peut pas généraliser au
delà de notre expérience il n'y a pas de
connaissance en dehors de l'expérience
il n'y a pas de connaissance
au delà de l'expérience et toutes nos
connaissances ne sont valables que dans
le segment de l'expérience vécue toute
généralisation et abusive tout
simplement parce que la généralisation
n'est pas un objet d'expérience
la généralisation n'est pas un objet
d'expérience c'est un procédé
intellectuelle c'est un procédé
spéculatifs mais ce n'est pas quelque
chose dont on peut avoir une
confirmation empirique
j'espère que vous saisissez ce que je
veux dire quand je dis que la
généralisation n'est pas un objet
d'expérience ce que je veux dire c'est
que autant la chaleur la colère la
fatigue
ce sont des objets d'expérience parce
que ce sont des choses sur lesquelles
vous pouvez poser des sensations en tout
cas posé le souvenir de sensations vous
pouvez par exemple vous représenter
visuellement quelqu'un de triste
quelqu'un de fatigué mais vous ne pouvez
pas vous représenter visuellement ce
qu'est la généralisation et bien parce
que la généralisation n'est pas un objet
d'expérience you may les empiristes nous
disent qu'il est impossible de
généraliser au delà de nos expériences
alors évidemment ça peut donner lieu à
des conclusions un petit peu farfelu ou
en tout cas qui nous paraîtront
farfelues comme par exemple de dire que
depuis que nous sommes nés nous avons vu
autour de nous des automobiles qui
possédait quatre roues et que donc il y
a toutes les raisons de croire que
toutes les automobiles possède 4 euros
en réalité
on peut pas l'affirmer par en être sûr à
100% il peut très bien y avoir des
voitures qui ont trois roues et
d'ailleurs ça existe il peut y avoir des
voitures qui ont siro viru et donc
l'idée qu'il n'existerait que des
voitures à quatre roues sur la seule
base de notre expérience c'est à dire du
simple fait que nous n'ayons vu que des
voitures à quatre roues
et bien cette généralisation est abusive
cette généralisation est abusive
puisqu'elle prétend étendre au delà de
nos expériences quelque chose qui
provient uniquement de nos expériences
donc c'est bien important de comprendre
que l'empirisme c'est un anti dogmatisme
anti dogmatisme ça signifie que pour un
empiriste la vérité ça n'existe pas la
vérité ça n'existe pas parce que par
définition la vérité c'est quelque chose
d'universel et d'intemporel la vérité ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui peut changer
en cours de route ce qui est vrai c'est
ce qui est établi de manière immuable
sauf qu' aucun être humain n'est teemu
abl donc aucun être humain ne peut faire
l'expérience de tout ce qui existe de
tout temps donc l'être humain est
fondamentalement incapable de dire
quelque chose qui puisse être vrai de
tout temps
l'être humain est incapable d'accéder à
la vérité à prendre
rist tout n'est que croyance tout n'est
que croyance c'est à dire tout n'est que
connaissances personnelles connaissances
issues de l'expérience
alors bien sûr les empiristes ne pense
pas que les connaissances rapportés par
exemple les connaissances scientifiques
ne soit pas valable
les empiristes ne dise pas que tout ce
qui provient d'autres expériences que la
nôtre ne doit pas être cru c'est pas ça
ce que produit la science ce sont des
connaissances issues d'expériences que
nous n'avons pas nous mêmes réalisés
mais que nous pouvons parfaitement
reproduire et c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
principes de la science moderne la
reproductibilité
nous sommes tous potentiellement capable
de reproduire une expérience dans les
conditions dans lesquelles elle a été
réalisée pour nous rendre compte que les
résultats sont les mêmes donc lorsqu'on
parle d'expérience
il ne s'agit pas de réduire à
l'expérience individuelle c'est pas
seulement l'expérience subjective ça
peut être l'expérience collective
l'expérience de la communauté par
exemple de la communauté scientifique
mais le fait est que même si on parle de
connaissances collectives
même si on parle de savoir partager ce
savoir n'est vrai que dans le cadre de
ce qu'ils ont ou qui ont pu
l'expérimenter
il n'y a pas de vérité car il n'y a pas
de connaissance
au delà de l'expérience et s'il n'y a
pas de connaissance au delà l'expérience
il n'y a pas de connaissance de ce qui
sera
il n'a pas de connaissance de ce qui
sera dans le futur puisque par
définition le futur ne nous est pas
connue donc vous voyez qu'il y a dans
l'empirisme une forme d'humilité
épistémologique
c'est à dire une sorte de prudence
vis-à-vis de ce qu'il nous est
impossible de connaître par définition
par définition il nous est impossible de
connaître ce dont nous n'avons pas fait
l'expérience il nous est impossible de
faire l'expérience du futur donc il nous
est impossible d'avoir une connaissance
de ce qui sera dans le futur
alors attention quand même c'est que
lorsqu'on dit qui nous est impossible
d'accéder à une quelconque forme de
vérité qui nous est impossible de
prédire que le soleil se lèvera demain
faut bien être d'accord pour yom
il n'est pas du tout absurde de croire
que le soleil se lèvera demain c'est
même une croyance parfaitement légitime
parfaitement rationnel même ce qui
serait absurde ce serait de croire que
tout ce qui s'est produit jusque là ne
se produira pas demain on est bien
d'accord
donc c'est une croyance tout à fait
légitime mais ce n'est pas parce qu'elle
est légitime qu'on peut affirmer qu'elle
est vrai ce n'est pas parce que cette
croyance est rationnel qu'on peut
affirmer que cette croyance est une
vérité vous voyez la différence
vous pouvez avoir confiance en quelqu'un
ça veut pas dire que cette personne ne
vous décevra jamais ça veut dire que
vous faites le pari qu'elle ne vous
décevra jamais donc tout n'est que
croyance au sens où tout ce que nous
croyons être vrai nous le croyons être
vrai alors ici il y à un cas qui est
souvent objecté à l'empirisme et auquel
l'empirisme d'ailleurs donne une réponse
c'est le quart de l'imagination
c'est le cas de ces images mentales que
nous sommes capables de produire et qui
pourtant ne résulte pas directement de
notre expérience on va prendre un un
exemple très simple on va prendre
l'exemple des créatures mythologiques
par exemple le minotaure donc le
minotaure c'est une créature
mythologique gardien du labyrinthe et ce
moteur a la particularité d'avoir un
corps d'homme et une tête de taureau
donc il est bien évident que à moins que
vous vous baladiez dans des endroits que
je ne connais pas vous avez rarement dû
rencontrer des hommes à tête de taureau
bon donc on pourrait en déduire que
cette création imaginaire du minotaure
contredit l'empirisme puisque voilà
qu'on invente une créature que personne
n'a observé dans la réalité à laquelle
personne n'a été confronté dans la vie
réelle donc on pourrait dire voilà un
exemple qui contredit l'empirisme
puisque le minotaure n'est pas issu de
nos expériences
la licorne n'est pas issue nos
expériences ne trouvent pas leur origine
dans la perception
oui mais non oui mais non parce que le
minotaure il est constitué de deux
éléments qui eux par contre sont des
objets d'expérience tout le monde a déjà
vu un homme tout le monde a déjà vu un
taureau donc tout le monde est capable
de se représenter la combinaison des
deux la combinaison de l'homme et du
taureau la combinaison de deux objets
d'expérience donc ce que nous disent les
empiristes c'est que tout ce que nous
imaginons tout ce que nous imaginons
c'est à dire toutes les images mentales
que nous produisons indépendamment de
l'expérience ne sont en réalité pas
indépendante de l'expérience
puisqu'elles sont des combinaisons des
associations d'objets d'expérience et
fait l'expérience par vous même c'est le
cas de le dire
essayez de vous représenter un être qui
possèderait des caractéristiques qui
possèderait des éléments constitutifs
dont vous n'auriez jamais fait
l'expérience
essayez d'imaginer vous allez voir que
c'est pas possible
vous allez voir que vous n'y arriverez
pas
parce que par définition ce dont vous
n'avez pas fait l'expérience
vous ne pouvez pas vous leur présentez
est d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve de
sens c'est qu'il nous arrive tous par
moment de faire l'expérience de la
nouveauté qu'est ce que c'est la
nouveauté c'est l'intrusion d'un élément
inconnu dans une situation connue
1 il faut bien qu'ils aient une
situation connue pour que la nouveauté
puis s'y introduire mais la nouveauté
c'est par exemple faire une expérience
musicale admettons une expérience
musicale qui ne sera en rien comparable
à toutes vos anciennes expériences
musicales ça existe mais si on vous
avait demandé avant l'expérience de
pouvoir vous représentez une telle
expérience
vous n'auriez pas pu le faire ça aurait
été tout simplement impossible tout
simplement parce que vous ne disposiez
pas de tous les éléments constitutifs de
cette nouvelle expérience pour un
empiriste l'imagination c'est donc la
capacité à créer des expériences
nouvelles
des objets nouveau à partir
d'expériences ou d'objets connu
voilà pourquoi d'un point de vue
empiriste l'imagination et finalement
quelque chose là ses limites et limité à
ce que nous connaissons déjà et à ce
qu'il nous est possible de créer à
partir de ce que nous connaissons déjà
alors on dirait c'est déjà pas mal parce
que le nombre de combinaisons que l'on
peut faire à partir de tout ce que l'on
connaît et déjà approche de l'infini
mais si on rajoute à ça le fait que nous
ne connaissons pas tous les éléments qui
existent que l'expérience de la
nouveauté quelque chose qui peut nous
arriver demain
il ya dans ce cas-là ça repousse encore
les limites de ce qu'il est possible de
connaître l'imagination ne contredit pas
l'idée que toutes nos connaissances
proviennent de l'expérience
l'imagination nous montre à quel point
nos connaissances ont déjà limités et
elles sont limitées parce que l'être
humain est en lui-même un être limitée
limitée dans le temps limité dans
l'espace limité dans ses capacités bien
l'idée que nous serions capables de nous
arracher de cette limitation vous
arrachez de cette finitude originaire
d'ars et une prétention que les
empiristes n'ont pas alors
et pour conclure cette vidéo on pourrait
certes faire le reproche aux empiriste
d'un certain manque d'ambition jusqu'à
près tous leurs discours consiste
surtout à insister sur nos incapacités
ou sur les limites de nos capacités nous
ne pouvons pas accéder à une quelconque
forme de vérité tout simplement parce
que nous ne pourrons jamais faire
l'expérience de tous pourront pas créé
de toute pièce quelque chose de nouveau
parce que tout ce que nous créons le
créons à partir de ce que nous
connaissons déjà mais malgré tout il
reste possible de d'inverser la vapeur
en se disant que ce qui reste possible
c'est la découverte de la nouveauté
car s'il est
interne être d'expérience il est capable
d'expérimenter ce qu'il ne connaît pas
encore et sam
ça lui laisse de la marge ça laisse à
l'homme la possibilité d'explorer tout
ce que la vie a à lui offrir et la vie
humaine regorge de choses que nous ne
connaissons pas encore on pourrait même
dire que chaque seconde qui passe est en
soi une expérience de la nouveauté
l'instant que vous vivez actuellement
est un instant parfaitement nouveau pour
vous chaque instant que vous vivez et un
instant nouveau et si on adopte cette
perspective si on adopte ce point de vue
selon lequel tout est nouveau et à ce
moment là on pourra se rendre compte que
l'expérience du monde est loin d'être
finie comme l'expérience du monde
n'appartient pas au passé
elle appartient au présent elle
appartient aux futurs elle appartient à
ce que nous en ferons
je vous remercie
[Musique]
et
ans